[Musik]
ich wollte meine wir befinden uns heute
am wasser übungsplatz in villach bei den
pionieren in italien 1 1 reichte den 150
tonnen kran meter tonnen kran vorstellen
zum
lkw selber wir haben eine länge vor und
10 meter fünfzig eine breite von 2 45
und eine höhe von 4 meter inklusive
krank das ganze hat 400 ps und wir holen
38 tonnen gut zum kran server das ist
ein ball finger kran wofür hat das ganze
als verwendung in verschiedenen us
einsätzen im brückenbau
unterstützungsleistungen und wenn wir
uns jetzt befinden beim brot erheben das
wars einmal grundsätzlich zum kran game
thomas voracek so wir befinden uns jetzt
hier bei einer nachforderung stützen und
durch mal gleich unser last diagramm das
ist eins der wichtigsten sachen ohne
diesen las diagramm bis schwer
herauszufinden beziehung
auswendig wissen was wir überhaupt geben
können wir haben hier zu sein ohne
fleisch chip eine ausleger länge von 14
metern wenn wir komplett auf die 14
meter heraus sind können wir
7,2 tonnen heben
so haben wir jetzt ein flagship dabei
haben wir eine gesamt ausleger länge von
28 metern und können bei dieser 28 meter
immer noch 1,2 tonnen heben so gerne
weiter
dora maar unser
bedienelement für die stützen
das ganze beginnen wir mit fernbedienung
und diesen hebeln die ersten zwei hebeln
sind für die vorderen für die vordere
spitze und die hinteren zwei für die
hintere stütze das war es zu diesem
bereich so jetzt immer auf der
unterseite durch grundsätzlich alles
gleich sprich wenn wieder los diagramm
wenn wieder die berlin hebel wichtig
dazu zogen ist ich kann immer nur auf
ana seiten der jeweiligen seiten
bedienen was soll man da noch wir haben
eine unterwegs flotten für was braucht
man jetzt sagen wir auf asphalt spricht
brauchen kann aber wenn wir uns auf anna
wiesen befinden brauchen wir natürlich
dass er unterwegs flotten oder
stapel hölzer und der weiteren warum gab
letztlich immer verdichtet seien
gut was irgendwann doch noch wir sehen
uns am haupttor und sein knie chor und
den ausleger mit den ganzen sachen
arbeiten wir und deko mieterverbänden
bedienen
sodass wollen jetzt mit unseren rundgang
wir sahen jetzt bei unserer führerkabine
ankommen ist ja gleich wie bei annahme
kw oder jetzt gemein screen von hans
sturm bot
[Musik]